on passe au fait du jour et cette 28e
campagne des Restos du cœur qui a débuté
hier Daniel Favier bonsoir vous êtes
donc le vice-président dans le
département des Yvelines des Restos du
cœur lancement hier de cette 28e
campagne nous irons tout à l'heure au
centre de stockage au clés sous-bois
nous irons aussi à la rencontre des
bénéficiaires des resto sur l'antenne de
plaisir tout d'abord un chiffre le
chiffre de cette édition 2000 c'est le
nombre de centres de distribution
alimentaire à travers la France il y en
a 24 dans les Yvelines est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour le département euh ce
n'est certainement pas suffisant puisque
nous ne couvrons pas la région de
Versailles la région de Sartrouville ou
carrière et même au niveau de la ville
nouvelle un nouveau centre serait le
bienvenu également il y a eu 115
millions de repas de distribués passé au
niveau national pour après auprès de
870000 personnes dans le département des
é ça représente quoi ça représente un
peu plus de 100002
13 repas servis euh pour on va dire 12
12800 personnes inscrites au niveau
national le président des Restos du cœur
he qui soulligne que le seuil des 870000
personnes au niveau national sera
certainement dépassé c'est en tout cas
l'inquiétude qu'il a qu'il a exprimé
c'était la 5e année consécutive l'an
dernier hein déjà de de hausse soit une
hausse de 30 % sur 5 ans oui vous
craignez aussi une hausse du nombre
bénéfici de personnes qui von évidemment
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'il y aurait
une diminution des personnes en grande
difficulté ça c'est évident quel le
pourcentage d'augmentation nous ne
pouvons pas l'imaginer pour l'instant
sachant que bah les inscriptions se font
régulièrement nous avons depuis 2 jours
je parle des ivelines depuis 2 jours des
centres qui sont en très grande
augmentation et d'autres qui ne le sont
pas c'est très irrégulier d'une ville à
l'autre sur le département mais nous
ferons un peu le point d'ici janvier par
là al nous allons partir pour le centre
de plaisir justement avec Valérie oribau
et Elodie moine à la rencontre des
bénéficiaires qui témoignent on se
retrouve ensuite en plateau pour
poursuivre la
discussion le 28e hiver commence pour
les resto du cœur de plaisir et le
nombre des bénéficiaires de l'aide
alimentaire explose 65 % de hausse en 6
ans avec ce constat la fréquentation des
femmes seules avec enfants a triplé
c'est la première fois que je viens ici
parce que j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
alors je viens ici depuis plusieurs
années on a une augmentation importante
des femmes seules avec enfants quelque
fois deux trois enfants ça c'est quelque
chose de très important les femmes ont
été les premières à ptir de la crise du
coup les restos du cœur s'organisent les
70 bénévoles formés à l'accueil et à
l'accompagnement orientent les femmes
vers les assistantes sociales ou la CAF
mais aussi vers l'accès aux soins tous
les mardis après midi une puirricultrice
ou une diététicienne reçoiv les mamans
le but privilégier le partage et
l'échange et pas seulement la
distribution de denrées alimentaires
rose bénéficiaire de longue date avec
son mari et son fils accompagne sa fille
qui vient de s'inscrire avec son enfant
de 5 ans ce sont parfois des familles
entières qui tombent dans la précarité
une précarité qui peut durer il y a
quelques années quand même déjà
ans on a un emploi on travaille un
emploi travaille on enregistré mais
c'est pas facile la vie est pas facile
quoi du tout l'an dernier les restos du
cœur de plaisir ont accueilli 375
familles et ici depuis 15 jours les
inscriptions pour les mois à venir ont
commencé avec une recrudescence de 15 à
20 % par rapport à
2011 voilà pour ce point sur le centre
de plaisir dans le département des
ivelines et pour ces témoignag aussi que
vous avez entendu principalement de
femmes de femmes isolées avec leurs
enfants c'est un profil qu'on retrouve
de plus en plus souvent pas uniquement à
plaisir bien sûr et puis ce n'est quand
même m pas très nouveau hein il y a
plusieurs années que nous avons la
preuve c'est que nous avons ouvert aussi
un resto bébé récemment à à un poissi un
autre à
rambouiller justement pour pouvoir
permettre à des mamans de se poser un
petit peu de poser leur enfant également
dans les bras de personnes compétentes
des bénévoles compétentes qui sont
toutes des anciennes professionnelles de
la santé ou de l'éducation ce qui leur
permet aux maman de pouvoir d'abord
discuter entre elles ne pas avoir l'
enfant dans les bras en permanence
l'enfant ou les enfants et de commencer
à parler entre les bénévoles et ell
entre ellmême et de faire des projets
éventuellement des rencontres euh à
poissie tous les lundis il y a une
rencontre pour l'instant entre femmes
turques elles ne connaissaient pas la
langue française mais nous allons pas
continuer longtemps de faire en sorte
que ces femmes restent entre elles nous
allons euh très vite les amener à
participer à des ateliers de français et
à entamer des des relations avec
d'autres personnes que les Turques on va
pas empêcher de se qu'elle se rencontre
entre elles bien évidemment mais on
voudrait vraiment qu'il y a une
véritable insertion et que de casser un
peu le communitarisme parce que vous
avez mentionné ces relais bébés ces
différentes actions qui sont menées ça
aussi c'est pas propre à cette année
c'est mené depuis plusieurs années mais
en tout cas ce sont des des missions qui
qui tiennent à cœur des des bénévoles on
ne fait pas uniquement de la
distribution alimentaire dans les restos
du cœur notamment dans le département de
l'accompagnement des chantiers insertion
les Restos Bébés vous les avez mentionné
des actions contre risme également dans
certains centres ou nous avons oui de
beaucoup de personnes qui viennent
maintenant s'inscrire et travailler mais
sous des forme plus ou moins ludique
pour maîtriser un peu mieux la langue
française à l'oral et à l'écrit pas
toujours dans un but d'insertion
professionnelle mais certainement dans
un but d'insertion sociale et c'est
quand même capital bien sûr pour
certains demandeurs d'asile c'est dans
un but d'insertion professionnelle
obtenir les les papiers une
régularisation sur le territoire
français et obtenir un logement et
obtenir un travail un c'est
indispensable justement de de combiner
ces ces différents aspects et pas
uniquement de la distribution
alimentaire sûr bien sûr alors vous
travaillez avec d'autres associations
sur ces différents points justement
parce que c'était pas la mission
première des resto en tout cas alors de
cration il y a plus alors euh nous
travaillons en partenariat avec des
structures d'accueil parce que nos
centres sont pas toujours adaptés à ce
genre d'activité par je pense
à aux ateliers de français et à
l'informatique dans certaines villes
nous travaillons en partenariat avec les
maisons de quartier poissis par exemple
ça fonctionne très bien nous avons 80
apprenants euh dans la maison de
quartier toutes les tous les après-midis
la maison de quartier du claudarcy prête
une salle au resto du cœur bravo merci
mais nous accueillons également des
personnes qui ne sont pas resto du cœur
h avec les nos personnes accueillies à
nous voilà donc euh ça c'est intéressant
c'est nouvelle forme de partenariat nous
avons aussi organisé des des Noëls des
des faites des manifestations avec les
autres associations caritatives du
département le Secours Catholique
bientôt Secours populaire voilà puisque
vous mentionnez ces autres associations
on va forcément parler des inquiétudes
que vous partagez avec toutes ces
associations caritatives puisque si vous
ne manquez pas d'activités la principale
inquiétude est autour du PEAD le plan
européen d'aide alimentaire depuis 1987
il permet de distribuer un repas 18
millions d'Européens dans le besoin donc
4 millions de français via des
associations comme les restos du cœur
devait être discuté en fin de semaine à
Bruxelles dans le cadre du budget
européen le maintien ou non de ce PEAD
ou en tout cas une solution de secours
les différents États-membres n'ont pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord l'Allemagne
ou encore la la Grande-Bretagne ne
souhaite pas le maintien de ce plan
d'aide il préférait que se mette en
place une solution comme dans leur
propre pays de système national de
redistribution euh aujourd'hui
véritablement si ce plan européens d'
devait disparaître vous en aviez déjà
parlé ne serait-ce que l'an dernier
lorsque vous étiez sur ce plateau eu ce
serait juste impossible pour vous de
continuer vos activités
B 23 ou 25 % de notre budget alimentaire
nous est fourni par l'Europe bon voilà
ce chiffre à lui seul suffit à expliquer
que nous aurions 25 % de produits de
denrée à de en moins à distribuer donc
si on maintenait
notre notre distribution actuelle il
faudrait qu'on trouve la compensation de
ces 25 % et nous les trouverons parce
que l'imagine ation des bénévoles et
sans limite leur disponibilité aussi je
tenais à le signaler souvent on en parle
comme ça mais il faut savoir ce que ça
représente votre journaliste qui est
allé à plaisir a dû s'en rendre compte
je tenais à le dire ici parce que c'est
important sans les bénévoles c'est
Coluche qui l'avait dit avant moi sans
les bénévoles en feraiit pas grand-chose
mais donc il faudrait qu'on trouve des
des des des façons de redistribuer à
imaginer je sais pas quoi comment ça se
passerait est-ce que l'État français
prendrait en partie le manque à gagner
je n'en sais rien rien moi ce que je
sais c'est que les collectivités locales
qui nous aident par des subventions le
le département qui nous aide par des
subventions
euh arrivve à des limites ils nous font
savoir ils nous le disent que la
subvention sera pas augmentée dans
certaines villes elle pourrait diminuer
malgré que on s'occupe de plus en plus
de des habitants de ces villes les dons
des particuliers qui représentent une
très gros grosse partie de nos
possibilités est-ce que ça on pourra
continuer sur à à demander sans cesse
nous sommes pas les seuls association à
demander il y a les
associations d'aide médicale et cetera
qui sont aussi très présentes le Téléton
va arriver euh reste les entreprises
alors alors il reste le Mesen ben oui
n'ayons pas peur des mots le mesena
pourquoi pas on se ferme pas cette porte
la preuve c'est que nous avons des
accord avec des grands groupes je vux
pas les citer là parce qu'il faudra que
j'en cite au moins trois je crois oui
c'est bien la VO noublier un trè non
donc pourquoi pas nous avons des accords
les entreprises et nous continuerons
bien sûr mais je suis pas convaincu non
plus que les entreprises à terme
pourront toujours aussi et cetera on va
arriver peut-être à se poser des vraies
questions de de répartition de
solidarité nationale ça veut dire qu'il
faut aussi repenser le fonctionnement
même des associations est-ce que les
associations ne devraient pas aussi
travailler ensemble peut-être
certainement mais c'est pas uniquement
ça je crois que jusqu'où on peut aller
jusqu'où euh les associations vont dans
est-ce que les collectivités locales
territoriales ne se défausent pas
toujours un pas un petit peu trop sur
les associations aussi ça veut dire que
même si les les les collectivités
territoriales ont pas beaucoup d'argent
il y a des priorités ce sont des choix
politiques et là c'est nos élus qui
doivent assumer leurs responsabilités
dans le reportage pardon dans le
reportage j'ai vu que les les
assistantes euh que nous envoyons que
les bénévoles accompagner les personnes
accueillies vers les services sociaux je
veis dire que réciproquement les
services sociaux nous envoient beaucoup
de monde pour queon fasse les dépannages
alimentaires on parlait de vos
inquiétudes dans le cadre de ce PEAD
depuis depuis quelques instants
notamment cette aide qui est versée au
niveau européen aux différentes
associations dont les restos du cœur
est-ce que dès cette année vous avez des
inquiétudes pour boucler le le budget
tout simplement pour aller jusqu'au
terme de la campagne jusqu'à la fin du
mois de mars non parce que je pense que
le budget
pour notre campagne d'hiver a déjà été
voté donc c'est on fonctionne sur
l'argent de l'année dernière après même
s'il y avait une forte hausse des
demandes oui mais la forte os nous
l'amortissons par nos par nos stocks n
là entre 5 et 10 % nous pouvons amortir
par les stocks en place par bon pour
autant les dons les collectes sont
importantes la grande collecte nationale
des restos c'est 8 ce sont les 8 et 9
mars est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
opérations pctuelles V ê organisé dans
le département bon il y a les
alors ça c'est pas dans le département
c'est national mais les qui
nous rapportent aussi pas mal d'argent
qui vont faire leur spectacle en janvier
je crois ça c'est une source de revenu
assez constante encore une fois je dis à
chaque fois qu'on me donne l'occasion
merci à Goldman qui a arrêté beaucoup
son activité professionnelle pour se
consacrer aux donc au resto je
dis bien donc au resto puisque c'est
exclusivement au profit des resto alors
localement bien sûr nous avons beaucoup
de
manifestations des des collectes
alimentaires ce son l'initiative des
centres de d'activité et là aussi bravo
les bénévoles qui n'hésitent pas à à à
œuvrer pour
récupérer de la de la nourriture nous
avons des opérations plus collectives
par exemple une opération de paquet
cadeaux dans un magasin de jouets de la
région de la région je vais pas citer le
nom mais il y en a qu'un là je peux pas
vous avez compris et qui rapporte un peu
d'argent puisque nous emballons les
jouets des des clients qui donnent ce
qu'ils veulent dans une urne nous avons
d'autres types de de il y a beaucoup
d'associations aussi qui organisent des
manifestations de musical et autres et
une partie de la recette nous est
reversée vraiment il y a une une grosse
grosse empathie de la part d'empathie
collective vis-à-vis des Restos du cœur
et qui nous permet de de fonctionner je
dois dire que nous en profitons pas nous
personnellement puisque notre
pourcentage de frais de siège de
fonctionnement il est de 6,9 %. je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup d'associations qui
pourraient qui ne qui ne n'ont pas ce
niveau de de dépenses puisqu'on parlait
du de la hausse du nombre de
bénéficiaires de personnes qui se
tournent vers vous on imagine que dans
les prochaines années ça pourrait encore
augmenter avec le le chômage qui
poursuit qui explose les derniers
chiffres viennent tout juste d'être
communiquer hein si vous nous suivez en
direct c'est autour de 45400 au niveau
national nouveaux demandeurs d'emploi
chômeur sur le mois d'octobre le chômage
donc qui explose vous craignez pas
forcément cette année mais dans les
prochaines années de les voir se tourner
vers vous c'est pas forcément immédiat
en tout cas la répercussion pour vous au
fur à mesure que les indemnisations des
chômeurs ne se feront plus pour des
raisons
organisationnelles forcément les gens
vont arriver vers nous vers nous
association caritative resto ou pas ça
c'est
évident il y aura de chômage plus nous
solliciter c'est hélas pour conclure
cette séquence je vous propose de partir
au clés sousbois c'est là que se trouve
le centre de de stockage des restau du
cœur dans le département des ivelines
l'entrepôt reportage Valérie oribau et
Elodie moine Maurice Glory est retraité
et bénévole au resto du cœur depuis plus
de 2 ans il s'occupe de l'entrepôt de
l'association basée aux clés sous-bois
l'année dernière l'équipe des bénévoles
a préparé 1400 palettes pour
approvisionner les 26 centres que compte
le département des ivelines on gère à
peu près 120 types de d'articles pour la
distribution donc ça va sur tout ce qui
est l'accompagnement classique les pâtes
le riz les conserves après vous avez
toute une série de prode euh tout ce qui
est conserve de poisson tout ce qui est
produits surgelés vous avez après du
dessert et des produits laitiers
l'objectif des resto fournir au
bénéficiaires un repas complet et
équilibré les besoins varieront selon
les centres les plus petits pourront
servir 120 repas par semaine tandis que
les plus importants en distribueront
4000 l'entrepô stock plus de 80 % de
marchandises alimentaires le reste se
réparti entre produits d'hygiène et
d'entretien pour les bébés couche laid
de croissance et petits pot destinés à
près de 500 nourriissons chaque semaine
si la campagne d'hiver des Restos du
cœur vient juste de débutter à
l'entrepôt on prépare déjà les palettes
pour la semaine suivante la distribution
commence ce matin et on est parti pour
officiellement 7 semaines mais
traditionalement on fait 17 semaines on
démarre en début en début de campagne à
45000 et on finira à plus de 60000 le
nombre de bénéficiaires ne cesse de
croître et les bénévoles sont plus que
jamais recherchés autre difficulté la
disparition du Programme européen d'aide
au plus démunis ça représente 20 25 %
des approvisionnements ici donc si brut
tellement ça disparî ben je pense qu'on
n pas de solution instantanée pour
remplacer ça donc on espère que les
politiques seront mobilisés pour
maintenir ce
budgetçon de faire et on voit l'action
he donc des bénévoles au quotidien dans
cette dans cet entrepôt il sont combien
dans le département à être mobilisé
combien de bénévoles travaillent
participe au resto du cœur alors nous
sommes 1000 bénévoles et nous
avons SEP salariés en CDD en CDI pardon
et puis actuellement quatre salariés à
l'entrepôt en CDD et 24 salariés en
insertion dans nos deux chantiers
d'insertion et toutes les bonnes
volontés sont évidemment les bienvenu
pour venir donc vous aider merci Daniel
Favier vice-président donc des Restos du
cœur dans le département des ivelines la
campagne des Restos 7 28e campagne qui
se poursuit elle se terminera le 17 mars
dans un instant dans le 78 environnement
solidarité toujours et puis citoyenneté
également avec de nouveaux invités pour
l'instant culture les monstres vous
allez le voir cela n'intéresse pas que
les enfants ils sont également très
présents dans la littérature pour adulte
direction morpa où se tient une
exposition actuellement reportage
Johanna souri et Guillaume
camps les monstres eff frais les
monstres fascinent ils ne laissent
personne indifférent un mois après
Halloween la médiathèque de Mor repa
vous invite à découvrir les créatures
fantastiques qui ont marqué la
littérature je suis assez fan de tout ce
qui est littérature fantastique de
science-fiction fantaisie et cetera et
je me suis toujours rendu compte que les
monstres sont partout dans la
littérature que ça fait vraiment partie
de quasiment de l'inconscient collectif
mais que quand on parle de monstrees on
parle aux enfants et pourtant les
monstres existent aussi pour les adultes
romans policiers science-fiction séries
télévisées ou encore blockbuster
américain les méchantes bêtes
envahissent nos livres et nos écrans
l'exemple parfait en ce moment c'est
Twilight qui fait un carton au cinéma
qui vient d'un d'un livre mais et qui
vient d'un bouquin de la fin du 19e
siècle Dracula de Braham Stoker je
voulais montrer aux adultes au public
adulte que ce ne sont absolument pas des
sous littérature et qu'aujourd'hui les
monstres sont effectivement partout au
fil de l'exposition le visiteur découvre
les grandes figures monstrueuses des
œuvres de référence comme la Bible on
passe évidemment par l'antiquité ensuite
les croyances moyenâgeuses autour du
Lougarou autour de ces grandes figures
monstrueuses le louarou le vampire et
cetera prenez les super-héros américains
Hulk par exemple est une adaptation de
docteur jaquill et mrter Hyde un regard
intéressant qui suscite un
questionnement sur les créatures
contemporaines comment les société crée
aussi les monstres comment il y a un
écho effectiv par rapport à des peurs
collectives ou des choses comme ça donc
c'est vrai qu'on s'est posé le problème
du monstre aujourd'hui c'est quoi notre
monstre les enfants ne seront pas en
reste puisqu'une exposition parallèle
leur présente les portraits des
personnages fantastiques incontournables
les monstrueuses littérature accueille
les visiteurs jusqu'au 30 novembre mais
des lectures seront organisées jusqu'en
décembre le programme complet est à
retrouver sur internet